in the last video i introduced a
constrained optimization problem where
we were trying to maximize this function
f of x y equals x squared times y but
subject to a constraint that your values
of x and y have to satisfy x squared
plus y squared equals one
and the way we were visualizing this was
to look at the x y plane where this
circle here represents our constraint
all of the points that make up this set
x squared plus y squared equals 1 and
then this curvy line here
is one of the contours of f meaning
we're setting f of x y equal to some
constant
and then i was varying around that
constant c so for high values of c the
contour would look something like this
this is where the value of x squared
times y is big and then for small values
of c
the contours would look like this so all
the points on this line would be f of x
y equals like 0.01 in this case
something like that
then the way to think about maximizing
this function is to try to increase that
value of c as much as you can without it
falling off the circle and the key
observation is that happens when they're
tangent so you know you might kind of
draw this out in a little sketch and say
there's some curve representing your
constraint which in this case would be
you know kind of where our circle is and
then the curve representing the contour
would just kiss that curve just barely
touch it in some way
now that's pretty but in terms of
solving the problem we still have some
work to do
and the main tool we're going to use
here is the gradient so let me go ahead
and draw a lot more contour lines than
there already are for x squared times y
so this is many of the contour lines and
i'll draw the gradient field the
gradient field of f
so i've made a video about the
relationship between the gradient and
contour lines and the upshot of it is
that these gradient vectors every time
they pass through a contour line they're
perpendicular to it
and the basic reason for that is if you
walk along the contour line the function
isn't changing value so if you want it
to change most rapidly you know it kind
of makes sense you should walk in the
perpendicular direction so that no
component of the walk that you're taking
is you know useless is along the line
where the function doesn't change
but again there's a whole video on that
that's worth checking out if this feels
unfamiliar
for our purposes what it means is that
when we're considering this point of
tangency the gradient of f at that point
is going to be some vector
perpendicular to both of the curves at
that point so that that little vector
represents the gradient of f at this
point on the plane
and we can do something very similar to
understand the other curve right now
i've just written it as a constraint x
squared plus y squared equals 1 but you
know to give that function a name let's
say that we've defined
g of x y
to be
x squared plus y squared
x squared plus y squared in that case
this constraint is pretty much just one
of the contour lines for the function g
and we can take a look at that if we go
over here and we look at all of the
other contour lines for this function g
and it should make sense that they're
circles because this function is x
squared plus y squared
and if we took a look at the gradient of
g and we go over and ask about the
gradient of g
it has that same property that every
gradient vector if it passes through a
contour line is perpendicular to it so
over on our drawing here the gradient
vector of g would also be perpendicular
to both these curves and you know maybe
in this case it's not as long as the
gradient of f or maybe it's longer
there's no reason that it would be the
same length but the important fact is
that it's proportional
and the way that we're going to write
this in formulas is to say that the
gradient of f evaluated let's see
evaluated at whatever the maximizing
value of x and y are so we should give
that a name probably maybe you know x
sub m y sub m the specific values of x
and y that are going to be at this point
that maximizes the function subject to
our constraint
so that's going to be related to the
gradient of g it's not going to be quite
equal so i'll leave some room here
related to the gradient of g
evaluated at that same point x m
y m
and like i said they're not equal
they're proportional so we need to have
some kind of proportionality constant in
there you almost always use the variable
lambda and this guy has a fancy name
it's called a lagrange multiplier
lagrange
lagrange was one of those
famous french mathematicians i always
get him confused with some of the other
french mathematicians at the time like
legendra or laplace there's a whole
bunch of things
let's see multiplier distracting myself
talking here
um
so lagrange multiplier so there's a
number of things in in multi-variable
calculus named after lagrange and this
is one of the big ones this this is a
technique that he
that he kind of developed or at the very
least popularized and the core idea is
to just set these gradients equal to
each other because that represents when
the contour line for one function is
tangent to the contour line of another
so this
this is something that we can actually
work with
and let's let's start working it out
right let's see what this translates to
in formulas so i already have g written
here so let's go ahead and just evaluate
what the gradient of g should be
and that's that's the gradient of x
squared plus y squared
and the way that we take our gradient is
it's going to be a vector
whose components are all the partial
derivatives so the first component is
the partial derivative with respect to x
so we treat x as a variable y looks like
a constant the derivative is 2x the
second component the partial derivative
with respect to y so now we're treating
y as the variable x is the constant so
the derivative looks like 2y
okay so that's the gradient of g then
the gradient of f
gradient of f
is going to look like gradient
of let's see what is x what is f it's x
squared times y
so x squared times y
we do the same thing
first component partial derivative with
respect to x x looks like a variable so
its derivative is 2 times x and then
that y looks like a constant when we're
up here
but then partial derivative with respect
to y that y looks like a variable that x
squared just looks like a constant
sitting in front of it
so that's what we get and now if we
kind of work out this lagrange
multiplier expression using these two
vectors
what we have written
what we're going to have written is that
this vector
2xy
x squared
is proportional with a proportionality
constant lambda
to
the gradient vector for g
to 2x
to y
and if you want you can think about this
as two separate equations i mean right
now it's one equation with vectors but
really what this is saying is you've got
two separate equations two times x y is
equal to
lambda gotta change colors a lot here
lambda
times 2x
gonna be a stickler for color
keep
keep read all of the things associated
with g
and then
the second equation is that x squared is
equal to lambda
times 2y
and
this might seem like a problem because
we have three unknowns x y and this new
lambda that we introduced kind of shot
ourselves in the foot by giving
ourselves a new variable to deal with
but we only have two equations so in
order to solve this we're going to need
three equations
and the third equation is something that
we've known the whole time it's been
part of the original problem it's the
constraint itself x squared plus y
x squared plus y squared excuse me
equals 1.
so that that third equation x squared
plus y squared is equal to 1.
so these are the three equations
that characterize our constrained
optimization problem the bottom one just
tells you that we have to be on this
this unit circle here so let me just
highlight it we have to be on this unit
circle and then these top two
tell us what's necessary in order for
our contour lines the contour of f and
the contour of g to be perfectly tangent
with each other
so
in the next video i'll go ahead and
solve this at this point it's pretty
much just algebra to deal with but it's
it's worth going through and then the
next couple ones i'll talk about a way
that you can encapsulate all three of
these equations into one expression
and also a little bit about the
interpretation of this lambda that we
introduced because it's not it's not
actually just a dummy variable it has a
pretty interesting meaning in physical
context once you're actually dealing
with a constrained optimization problem
in practice so i'll see you next video